[Música]
cuántos de ustedes no han disfrutado una
buena fiesta más allá que se sorprenden
porque ya están cantando los pajaritos
levanten la mano
pues hace 12 años en una de esas buenas
fiestas de navidad
yo escuché esto al llegar a mi casa
esto
cuantos medios prendidos logré reconocer
esa especie
bueno esta es una representación gráfica
del sonido con lo cual nosotros los
biólogos trabajamos donde tenemos el
tiempo ustedes veían que la barrita iba
cantando y a medida que salen esas notas
extrañas pues es el sonido y esto
pertenece a esta belleza de paz pájaro
muy común acá en la sabana de bogotá una
mira gris mi isla grande turdus busca
ter para en 3
y se le reconocen porque ese contraste
entre las patitas naranjas el pico
naranja de hecho yo sé que este es un
macho porque tiene un anillo alrededor
del ojo que es naranja también la hembra
lo tiene negro entonces ya ustedes
se van a ir de acá con un nuevo
conocimiento
y cuando yo empecé a estudiar esto y
dije yo tengo que aprender un poquito
más de esta gran biodiversidad entonces
orlando joven con pelo empezó a pasar
jazz
y pues este es una gráfica que me ayuda
a explicar los patrones globales de
diversidad en términos del número de
especies para tres grupos aves mamíferos
y anfibios para los que salieron del
colegio tal como yo vistes aves maman
seis mamíferos y anfibios esan finas
y usted es esa figura me sirve para
ubicar los trópicos y es que miren el
valor máximo en las barritas el valor
más rojito los puntos más calientes de
diversidad están concentrados en los
trópicos
y de hecho colombia está justo en esa
frase entonces imagínense un joven
orlando feliz de salir a pasear en toda
esta diversidad
y ustedes dirán bien por ti tú decidiste
levantarte todos los días a las 4 de la
mañana a mirar pajaritos o bien por
aquel que le gusta [ __ ] ranas en la
mitad de la noche o bien por aquel que
se mete en un charco sacar pescados y el
resto que bueno pues resulta que la
biodiversidad presta unos servicios
ecosistémicos muy importantes dentro de
unos ciclos ecológicos
de funcionamiento de toda la naturaleza
que nos rodea me explico por ejemplo
este estudio cálculo o estimo para el
perdón la tasa de consumo de insectos de
artrópodos que pueden ser plagas para
cultivos por ejemplo y la estimó entre
400 y 500 millones de toneladas de
insectos al año que se comen solo las
aves insectívoras vea qué tan bueno un
servicio ecosistémico que se puede
transferir a fondos y esa es una parte
de los servicios ecosistémicos que uno
puede percibir tal vez en su bolsillo si
tú eres un agricultor hay otros
servicios ecosistémicos que no se pueden
percibir tan fácil como la polinización
como este colibrí que ustedes encuentran
acá en los cerros de bogotá visitando
una curva
y muchas aves dispersando semillas y no
solo aves murciélagos y de todo
pero resulta que esa esa funcionalidad
que a veces no vemos pues tal vez puede
también referirse a ingresos esto es un
análisis desactualizado perdón
orlando es que en que era viví este 2011
y usted se sorprendería que en 2011 3
millones de vuelos internacionales
partieron sólo con el objetivo de ir a
mirar pajaritos
más de 48 millones de dólares en
ecoturismo gastan los norteamericanos
para ir a ver a pajaritos donde se
concentran la mayor número de diversidad
de aves en los trópicos entonces
imagínense esto puede ser un nuevo
mercado que de hecho ahorita se está
abriendo al país
también por ejemplo de salud pública
estos son unos buitres perdón no son
colombianos son unos buitres del viejo
mundo son de la india y resulta que en
una escala de sólo 10 años la población
declinó tanto tan
barbaria mente qué
empezó a proliferar las ratas y los
perros federales si ustedes ven esos
buitres de que se están alimentando de
un muerto o sea de cadáveres cuando ya
no están los buitres todos esos
cadáveres quedan a disposición de ratas
y de perros y los ratas y perros traen
rabia y de hecho en la india la
incidencia de rabia creció a altamente
correlacionada con el declinamiento de
los buitres entonces de hecho se estimó
que sólo con tener poblaciones
saludables de buitres ustedes pueden
prevenir 2.4 billones de dólares en
salud pública entre tratar enfermos e
inclusive muertes humanas
no siendo más un estudio presentado este
año de 27 países en vías de desarrollo
encontraron que la cercanía de los
bosques por diferentes mecanismos
aumenta la diversidad dietaria en los
niños es decir la conclusión de ellos es
que entre más bosque más diversidad
dietarias niños porque aporta una
nutrición de micronutrientes que no
tienen de otro modo eso ocurre en los
países en vías de desarrollo
entonces el día de hoy yo lo que quiero
es que ustedes salgan con los sentidos
abiertos y ahora les voy a pedir el
favor de que cierren sus ojos
y esta voy a hacer la primera de muchas
veces que lo van a hacer perdón pero
pues así la diseñamos
puede abrir los ojos y levantar la mano
a los que conocen ese sonido
un gorrión gorrión copetón cierto es el
más serio de los cachacos claro él tiene
un corbatín citó tiene una bufanda
color ladrillo y tiene el copete que
parece un sombrerito cualquier persona
puede identificar ahorita a salir de
este auditorio o los que están viendo un
stream en en facebook
un copetón que llega a su patio tal vez
lo que muchos no sospechan es que este
habitante tan común
de la sabana de bogotá o de las ciudades
andinas como quindío armenia
tiene que modificar su comportamiento
por culpa de los humanos como así en
lugares donde hay más ruido antrópico
más trancones ellos empiezan a cantar
menos la más temprana mientras que en
ruidos menos en lugares menos ruidosos
empieza a cantar mucho más tarde eso fue
un estudio que hicieron aquí mismo en la
ciudad de bogotá
entonces la biodiversidad trae un montón
de mensajes ocultos y tal vez los
sonidos pueden ser un modo de
estudiarlos y de conectarnos con esa
naturaleza ahora los voy a invitar a que
se sientan como aviones y fuimos a un
bosque en el piedemonte andino amazónico
de mocoa donde si ustedes ven el tamaño
de esa personita es más o menos unos 170
entonces tienes un perfil vertical casi
de 30 metros y si tú estás buscando
pajaritos de este tamaño pues va a ser
muy complicado sin embargo en la parte
más baja del bosque que nosotros lo
llamamos auto bosque tú empiezas a
escuchar esto
y gracias a que alguien fue al campo y
grabó ese sonido y lo asocio con un
espécimen pues podemos saber que eso es
un dínamo un tipo de gallineta que vive
solo en la parte baja del bosque pero en
el estrato medio también puedes tener
esto
y de igual forma alguien se tomó la
tarea de estudiar este animalito antes y
sabemos que es un hormiguero banda
y en el dosel en la copa de los árboles
también uno podría tener es
que pertenece a este atrapamos a es
diminuto
y entonces uno se arma de equipo sale al
campo ya sin pelo y empieza a grabar
todos esos mensajes de la naturaleza a
intentar descifrar los y los lleva a
repositorios como colecciones biológicas
en este caso colecciones biológicas
digitales
ok pero de hecho cuando uno se arma de
aquí de ese equipo para salir el mundo
puede ir un poquito más allá y ese es el
caso de juan pablo curas en uruguay o
como muchos que hay aunque dicen que
uruguay es tan chiquito que todo se
conocen
pero este uruguayo por consejos de un
ornitólogo empezó a grabar los sonidos
de la naturaleza
él es quién
y él desde su condición nos trae tres
mensajes importantes primero tenemos
oídos pero no sabemos utilizarlos
segundo somos prisioneros de la
información que entra por los ojos hasta
no ver no creer
pero cuando tú despiertas los sentidos y
puedes hacerlo los oídos nos permiten
entrar a otro mundo
entonces
vamos a ver otra forma esto que tengo
aquí o eso que está allí es tal vez uno
de los pájaros más bonitos que uno pueda
encontrar en los bosques colombianos una
de las 1900 especies de aves que hay el
país con más número de especies de aves
en el mundo y una belleza la tangana de
siete colores tangara chilenas y les
llamamos es familiar de los azulejos que
les gustaban a la tía
pero si tú tienes una deficiencia en
visión tal vez esos colores tan
espectaculares empiezan a modificarse a
cambiar y me hago por aquí para si estoy
tapando alguien que lo vean bien pero
resulta que si tú tienes una grabadora o
tu celular o sales al campo y conoces el
canto el canto
ahora vamos a ir al sur de colombia al
valle de sibundoy un lugar mágico
imagínense es como una sabana de bogotá
pero en chiquito
fue una vez un lago está rodeado de
montañas llenas de bosques ustedes están
parados al borde del bosque y desde el
bosque van a escuchar eso vuelvan a
cerrar los ojos
[Música]
de hecho este pajarito ustedes también
lo encuentran aquí en los cerros allí
atrás
en bogotá le conocemos como compra pan
pero es el lugar mágico segundo hoy una
familia de cansada de los indígenas que
habitan ese lugar pensaba que era un
espíritu que protegía la montaña y el
territorio de ellos y ellos su apellido
lo adoptaron de cómo suena este
animalito son de apellido chico aunque
entonces empiezas a vincular la
biodiversidad que te rodea con tu propia
esencia como humano y es esta belleza de
animal algo muy difícil a veces de
fotografiar pero cuando cuando está en
un bosque ustedes lo escuchan a toda
hora
ahora
nos vamos a ubicar en un bosque bajo
puede ser la amazonía puede ser en
montes de maría donde yo conocí este
pajarito son las siete siete y media de
la noche tú estás volviendo de una
caminata de pajarear después de ver
guacamayas y tucanes estás feliz
extasiado rodeado de 15 estudiantes
porque eres monitor eres el niño niño
que el anterior semestre fue el niño y
entonces eres monitor y entonces te la
sabes todas y caminas a esto el piso y
yo soy pajarero
y pueden cerrar los ojos
y suena esto
[Música]
pues después de entender que era un
reparado o madre luna de hecho es un ave
nocturna que de día se tiene que
camuflar muy bien para que no lo
molesten los depredadores no lo detecten
las posibles presas y los que no lo ven
allá arriba te que al pico también le
llaman mira pal 7 porque siempre está
como así y le dice madre luna porque en
las noches de luna canta mucho más
mick tibios gris
ahora vamos a ir lejísimos ustedes
espera un viaje absurdo vamos a ir
lejísimos al caminito de allí en atrás
y en un momento ustedes vinieron tarde o
están cansados por los exámenes finales
se sentaron a comer una
no sé cualquier cosa se sentaron ahí al
lado de un árbol y escuchan esto si
quieren ser re los ojos
y levanten la mano los que han escuchado
eso en su campus direccionado
y han visto que pajarito es levanten la
mano el que los ha visto
pues es esta majestuosidad así que la
próxima vez que lo escuchen váyase de
atrás a ver qué es pero entonces no sólo
los pajaritos están lanzando esos
mensajes
escuchen
y levanten la mano quienes escucharon el
trueno
pues la tierra la madre tierra también
nos habla y cuando la tierra emite
sonidos nosotros los niños del paisaje
son lo que conocemos como geo font ya él
el río la quebrada el trueno volcanes
eructando todo eso se parte de ese
paisaje solo
está digamos que ustedes iban por la 26
después de la marcha y cerca de la
nacional de esos praditos que hay
empezaron a escuchar eso que es esta
belleza de rana es parte de la
biodiversidad pero como es biodiversidad
que suena pues nosotros lo llamamos bio
fonía
pero no solo las ranas y aves están
mandando mensajes
de hecho este sonido fue tomado durante
mi pregrado en el piedemonte araucano en
tame arauca y era esta belleza que me
quitó un chico esta especie o este taxón
sólo habita colombia los andes
colombianos y está en peligro crítico
porque porque está perdiendo su hábitat
y el último componente pues esa
antropología pero yo creo que todos le
gustamos de un lindo tren como para
llegar entonces no les voy a poner
sonidos de trancones y pitos
lo que les quiero decir es todos
empezamos podemos empezar a ver hacia
nuestro entorno y empezar a entender esa
biodiversidad que nos quiere hablar
muchas veces yo soy uno de muchos
biólogos de campo que están recorriendo
el país para traerles a ustedes
esa biodiversidad y esos mensajes que
nos tiene la biodiversidad al alcance de
un libro o en pantallas es un trabajo
arduo pero pero lo tenemos que hacer y
finalmente ya para terminar les quiero
dar un regalo y es que este pajarito que
ustedes van a ver
se dice en la amazonía que cuando las
personas lo escuchan
son felices de ese momento y por el
resto de sus vidas así que no me queda
más que decirles que sean felices
[Aplausos]